afters do not get away o Thurs the
second try
here comes simmons between them thank
you to our gmt studios nana scattered
authority 2018 if you want to watch an
NBA game in 2018
[Applause]
a Honda driving the game John Wall loves
to finish with that left hand and he
does so with authority the inaugural
Honda truck
[Applause]
know what this kid is not a joke he's an
NBA player he's one of the best in the
world simply sitting at home joking
about him
Sandler picks him up on a switch that's
huccha [ __ ] driving the time Lando's go
to the free-throw line and shot one
free-throw as a team
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he pulls it in yeah this is going to
have a lot of rebounds this year that's
my perception is that a lot of those two
to ten points the Bucks up five thirty
to twenty five stick around NBA
Commissioner Adam Silver will join us at
five sir form next puncture that one Oh
Dumas the entire bits got up on that one
oh my goodness young man Creek Evans
gets it and you can see Lopez is back
take that oh very nice
pick and roll see it take no chances
and Sabonis with another chance in his
second three-point play in another look
high scoring first half rubio sees the
opening pressure on Golden State little
treading into the paint is Rubio and go
back you forced to step up by Damien
hustle that's what I'm talking about
bring it force let's think about the guy
was at home without a job pardon blows
past James head throws it down anytime
beyond the arc Hornets came in with 33
triples in their first two games that's
the most of the league for Derrick Jones
jr. that's athleticism the crossover and
here comes the pike as he rises head
above the rim one more look take that
that's athleticism the crossover and
here comes the pike as he rises see
hakama passed out low pulled away and
wall has the steal
can it go all the way lay it up no good
gray
off to the races John Wall attacks
heyyo don't hurt him young fella the
play with the strong left-handed finish
shot clock is off
Hardaway to tree
[Applause]
surprisingly never with the nasty stuff
[Music]
15 points for the rookie mix-up big as
we head to the fourth on opening up
as crowd goes up
challenges JoEllen be
the content this sugar than one looking
at mb goes up with both hands
[Applause]
Brown finds away
[Applause]
yeah and the level of commitment that
this guy is shown
[Applause]